hier soir après la tragique disparition
de la reine elizabeth 2 des millions de
messages d'amour et de soutien ont été
postés sur les réseaux sociaux n'ont
plus de 1800 tweets à la seconde un
record historique mais parmi tous ces
messages on est aussi tombé sur celui
des oceanes une candidate de
télé-réalité qui a confondu la reine
d'angleterre et brigitte macro
suite à cette énorme boulette elle est
devenue la risée d'internet et a dû
s'expliquer sur les réseaux sociaux je
pensais sincèrement en voyant à selon
l'avis que fidji c'est vrai était décédé
certains se sont amusés de cette bourde
d'autres l'ont trouvé choquant alors
comprenez vous ce déferlement
alors bernard est ce que vous vous êtes
choqués est-ce que non non non non est
ce que est ce que madame lalala bien
pris ah ça je ne sais pas si c'était
aujourd'hui mais la belle ibérique se
termine sur balles vous serez quand la
semaine prochaine
on l'appelait pour cette bêtise et il se
trouve que je sais quel art poster d'un
autre juin sert
la personne on la connaît à la halle un
bal un train dimitri alain boal un beau
palmarès et un beau palmarès ah bah oui
beau palmarès à la donc fait les princes
et princesses de l'amour avait également
enchaîné avec un autre celle de
marseille aux caraïbes elle a fait
moundir les apôtres il ya des apprentis
aventuriers marseillais contre le reste
du monde ficelles même parcours
merci pour cette petite précision sa
tête mais voilà moi je sis et pécs
prennent ça pousse ça peut être drôle
est ce que c'est une honte non en fait
c'est elle a été victime entre
guillemets de l'immédiateté d'instagram
sarca l'avion d'un de ses amis qui a
posté cette story qui était à la base
une vanne et elle l art poster sans
savoir m'étonner après
l'accroc l appât confondues mais je
m'accroche avec l arrêt des mandats
vraies photos de brigitte apporte que
selena elle a vu un ami de la story elle
a pris ça pour une la repousse des sans
penser à la réalisable est donc elle a
été un peu victime dans sa g et
brigitte est né en 1926
on n'est pas loin
oh
mais qui respecte et vous alors ma mère
la petite ma mère et ma femme également
et le respect aussi moi même c'est déjà
pas si mal oui madame et en parlant de
respect moi c'est ce audrin dimitris que
je ne connaissent absolument pas qui a
fait cette vanne très très douteuse sur
la première dame donc ça et la pop elle
a été victime de son inculture mais pour
une fois je défends une influence et sa
faune et bien on aime parce que ce sera
pas souvent mais franchement on lui est
tombé dessus parce que c'est évidemment
elle la plus connue mais c'est un
mauvais procès et voilà c'est juste qu'à
leur agrément raymond raymond est
choquée moi je suis choquée parce que
ces raisons c'est des influenceurs tout
ça ils savent ce qu'ils font ils savent
ce qu'ils passent ils sont censés savoir
attend essentiel et savoir ce qu'ils
postent quand c'est pour poster des
produits qui va leur apporter de
l'oseille il fait attention comme est là
on l'a pas toujours
mais ils sont capables d'encaisser
n'osait ils sont capables de faire
attention là là combien d'abonnés 7,1
millions fille millions débute pas une
photo comme ça de josh s'est excusé de
la france on s'en fout ça c'est pas une
photo de la première note quant à 1
million d'ha bonheur n'était pas en
train de faire quatre abonnés là on sait
que c'est à elle pensait elle pensait
quand tu respectes les gens quant à une
éducation tu vas tu vas sur internet tu
te renseignes tu vois sur google et
d'accès confirmée par les médias tu dis
tu fais un hommage mais là je trouve
c'est très bon et je trouve que ça
serait pas
[Applaudissements]
le cas vous auriez vous vous auriez pu
riposte ce non non non non non mais je
pose la question mais moi je pense
qu'elle a vite voulu faire le buzz et
puis mais le résultat est là bien réussi
parce qu'on parle d'elle en ce moment
mais ces résultats alors je sais pas si
tu as très partiales et vit des moments
où serein sûr sur les réseaux à jour mon
avis peut-être qu'à pas fait exprès
aussi mais je pense que fin aussi c'est
pas possible en fait sur safran c'est
saint cyr et elles font ce genre jeudi
les morts annoncés par accident il a dit
oui on a lancé notre mort oui c'est vrai
on annoncé ma mort ou deux fois deux
fois mais pourquoi alors ces parias
notamment qu'il espère deux fois oui
j'ai dû j'ai dû aller sur le plateau de
lci à l'époque carrément ah oui oui
parce que ce nom mais parce que sur le
coup ça vous fait rire quand on dit que
vous êtes mort en face à vous fait rire
chez moyens drôle quand c'est des
conneries mais après quand votre mère
vous appelle que vos frères et ma soeur
tout le monde appelle inquiet les amis
la famille tous là tu dit alors que de
réagir juste une question c'est parce
que si si votre mère et votre ami ça les
inquiète d'apprendre qu'il est mort si
vous êtes quand même ça ils font pas
très bien informé quand même maintenant
vous savez quand à la vie comme à moi je
suis bordelais donc je vis à paris donc
tout peut t'arriver un sorbet ya cinq
ans moi aussi on annonçait même failli
oui mais c'est de l'anticipation
[Rires]
enfin quand vous recevez un premier
bilan c'est bien parce qu'il ya la date
de sa mort c'est aujourd'hui sur
wikipédia ça fait flipper et appel et en
plus ce qu'il m'a dit que peut-être
c'était justement une anticipation un
voyant davantage journée j'ai flippé
fait que c'était ma dernière c'était en
quelle année fait il ya cinq ans mais
jean piot quand on vous annonce que vous
êtes membre vous y croyez vous
[Rires]
alors tous les biens collectifs quand
même
envoyé sur wikipédia la balade du jour
votre nom bah ça fait flipper chez c'est
vrai je suis pas très connu qui a pu
écrire ça bat jamais